süßigkeiten in knallbunten farben
das schreit doch nach chemie und
ungesunden farbstoffen
aber nichts da und das geht auch
natürlich und zwar mit farbstoff aus
algen wie die industrie das macht und
wie man aus grünen algen plötzlich
blauen farbstoff herauskitzelt weiß
sebastian liege besonders bei süss kam
scheint je bunter desto besser doch
synthetische farbstoffe gelten als
schädlich und stehen oft in der kritik
[Musik]
die lösung der industrie wächst hier in
sachsen anhalt und sie ist klein und
grün algen genauer gesagt mikroalgen
jörg ullmann ist er herr über das eigene
mehr
im prinzip steht hier ein riesiges
aquarium motors wird das aquarium nicht
eckig gebaut haben sondern im röhren vor
in dem 500 kilometer langen röhren
system wachsen die algen vor sich hin
wichtig ganz viel licht nur so bildet
sich genügend chlorophyll denn das ist
am ende verantwortlich für die grüne
farbe
nach der ernte werden die allen
getrocknet und so pulver gemahlen und
fertig ist eher natürliche grüne
farbstoff aber die alge kann mehr als
gut
sebastian liege meist wie jetzt ist die
eigener grünen aber gleich zaubere ich
daraus strahlend laufe aber dafür nimmt
sebastian spirulina algen aufgelöst in
wasser um an den blauen farbstoff zu
kommen muss er das grüne chlorophyll
loswerden
der trick filtern filtern filtern und
warten
[Musik]
die industrie hat hochdruck pressen mit
extrem feinen filtern
sebastian hat dafür eine große spritze
die hat mir mein kumpel aus dem zoo
geliehen nämlich eine echte elefanten
spritze damit erzeugt sebastian jetzt
druck und jagt die algen flüssigkeit
durch ein mikro filter der findet auch
die letzten chlorophyll partikel raus
übrig bleibt
strahlend blaue farbe ist das cool
sebastian freis und die industrie erst
recht
aus den blauen und grünen farbpigmenten
können durch verschiedenste zu setzen
ganz viele unterschiedliche farben
entstehen
[Musik]
also keine chemie keine schädlichen
nebenwirkungen zur abwechslung mal ein
ganz natürlicher trick der
lebensmittelindustrie jedoch übrigens
der blauen farbstoff aus der alge ist
ein spezielles eiweißmolekül und heißt
für co2
falls ihr mal mit einem fremdwort
angeben wollte noch mehr kunterbunte
tricks checks und duelle aus der welt
der lebensmittel findet ihr auf unserem
kanal zdf besser esser